so today we're gonna do a deep dive on
things that will potentially break your
fast and things that may not break your
fast so the topic of breaking your fast
seems to come up over and over and over
as far as a major confusion for a lot of
people so I'm gonna take each little
part of this in attempt to try to help
you understand it in a very simple way
well see if I could pull it off
a true fast and we're talking about a
water fast involves not eating and only
drinking water nothing else okay so if
you were to consume vitamins or coffee
or anything you are breaking the fast
okay
dry fast you're not consuming any water
you're not eating anything okay that's
the dry fastest now what I want to get
into is the degrees of breaking a fast
because there's a lot of things that
will on a very minor way possibly break
your fast but only in a temporary way
maybe for only 20 minutes to a half-hour
so I am gonna recommend consuming
certain things during your fast because
it's a real minor point it's nothing to
put attention on and but I want you to
understand the relative degrees of
things that will break your fast versus
those things that are very very tiny
that will only break your fast a little
bit and for a short period of time but
we also have to differentiate between
bumping you out of ketosis that seems to
be a confusion as well ketosis is the
state of producing ketones from fat now
if you're consuming MCT oil or exogenous
ketones as a supplement okay you're
gonna be in ketosis regardless of what
you eat in regardless of what's
happening with your own fat so let's
differentiate your body making ketones
like your liver actually producing
ketones from your own fat versus you
taking ketones externally and your
body's not actually making your own
ketones now the reason I'm bringing that
up is this right here things that bump
you out of fat-burning now if you're
taking eggs agendas ketones okay as a
supplement or MCT oil or coconut oil or
consuming butter
you'll be in ketosis but you're not
necessarily going to be bringing fat
because your body is using the dietary
fat or the dietary ketones instead of
your own reserve okay so we have the
degree of fat burning that you're in and
then we have the level of ketosis and
then we have fasting now the main
benefit of being in a fast are these
four things right here ketosis etaf EG
decreasing insulin and evaporating each
one of these is a huge benefit just
being ketosis will help you lose weight
help your brain regenerate give you
energy I mean think about it ketones are
antioxidants it's going to reduce
oxidation in your body so it's gonna
actually counter a lot of disease
processes also ketones will feed a
damaged heart better than glucose
ketones will feed a damaged brain better
than glucose so there's a lot of
benefits of being in ketosis and also
even taking ketones in general at otha G
okay the benefits of tapa G from going
on a fast are huge you get to recycle
old damaged proteins you're actually
cleaning up microbes Candida viruses
from the body this is very anti aging
and you're also recycling other
nutrients as well and I'll probably do a
separate video just on this one topic
but as soon as you start consuming carbs
to any degree you're gonna slow down a
toughie G eating protein will also slow
down a toughie G so it true fast is the
ultimate way but if you're taking
supplements for example it's going to be
a very minor fact on this right here
it's going to inhibit the top of G only
a tiny bit because there's barely any
calories so we have to look at the
quantity of calories are those calories
more carbohydrate are they protein are
they're fat I'm going to do a separate
video just on that but the point is that
etapa G is a huge benefit of what's
going on fast also the benefit of
lowering insulin is huge - and
helps to reverse a fatty liver and helps
to improve your cholesterol and lipid
profile it helps the brain in general
it helps diabetes insulin resistance and
the list goes on and on and on including
also acne as well alright then we have
the benefit of fat burning well weight
loss is a great benefit of burning fat
also your hunger goes down I forgot to
mention that with all of these right
here so basically you're not hunger
anymore so your cravings go away now
when we're talking about breaking a fast
we really just need to know what will
create the the most smallest effect on
insulin the more insulin you have in
your body the greater this is gonna
knock you out of being in a fast and the
less benefits you're gonna have so the
more refined the carbohydrate is the
higher that food is on that glycemic
index the worse the effect the worst
food that you can consume is something
called multi dextran which it's
surprising that is in a lot of so called
keto friendly foods or snacks that they
sell and then we have protein protein
also has the effect of breaking it fast
because it increases insulin not to
agree that a carbohydrate will but to a
large degree especially if you're
consuming a larger quantities of protein
then calories in general despite what
those calories are because the calories
that you consume trigger something in
your small intestine that triggers
insulin to go up okay so we really have
calories and protein in carbs now there
are things that have a zero effect on
insulin like fiber and fat but if you're
consuming large amounts of fiber or fat
with calories it could influence insulin
a small amount okay but if we compare
this to this these are these are higher
also realize when you consume fiber you
can't digest fiber so the microbes
digest it and the effect of your
microbes consuming fiber you can't
digest it your microbes digest it they
consume it and then they release this
thing called butyrate which is ketone
like and indirectly it'll help your
blood sugars and
reduce insulin so fiber is actually very
very good to help with blood sugar
problems in reducing insulin but of
course if you consume a tremendous
amount of fat it's going to raise
insulin a small amount just for the fact
of these calories right here okay so
hope you have that so far let's go to
the next page right here okay
so I kind of created a list here of
looking at insulin ketones and actual
weight loss and I already covered the
benefit so you know the benefit of this
lowering insulin the benefit of this and
fat burning and of course at Apogee but
that one's going to be for a separate
video so let's take a look at coffee
coffee really is going to have a
insignificant effect on insulin okay
it's a small amount of calories there's
hardly any carbs in there hardly any
protein so it's going to have a zero
effect on ketones and a zero effect on
weight loss or weak weight gain now if
you consume a tremendous amount of
coffee with all the caffeine it could
increase cortisol potentially that could
actually activate insulin so stress can
make you fat because stress mobilizes
your own protein which then will be
converted into sugar which then could
raise insulin too so I just want to
bring that up and then we have tea tea
pretty much has a zero effect on insulin
it's much less in caffeine zero effect
on ketones zero effect on weight loss so
even though the true definition of a
water fast is just drinking water
nothing else
none of these I'm still going to
recommend some of these because it's
going to create just this a very very
small effect which is basically
insignificant okay because we're looking
at the effect on insulin in fact on
ketones and is it going to stop your
weight loss
okay gum well that really depends on
what kind of gum you're chewing okay if
you're doing a sugar-free gum it's gonna
have a very small effect on insulin
ketones and weight loss unless it has
something called aspartame or NutraSweet
the problem with this is that it affects
your microbes in a way that can lead to
insulin resistance I'm gonna put a link
down below for more data on this if you
want to have a deep dive and exactly
what it does but it studies show of
course in mice not in humans but just as
a side note from working with tens of
thousands of people over the years I
have noticed that those people who
consume this chronically nearly always
have a way problem so this chemical does
affect our gut which can lead to insulin
resistance which can increase insulin
especially if it's done chronically so
this depends what type of gum if it's
sweetened with xylitol you're just
talking about a very very small amount
even though Azana tall is a sugar
alcohol and it's not zero on the
glycemic index it's like thirty it's
such a small amount it's really going to
be an insignificant effect of insulin
ketones and weight loss so I wouldn't
even worry about this right here of
course if you're chewing regular gum
with sugar that is a problem because
there's a lot of sugar in gum vitamins
near zero effect on insulin ketones and
weight loss either up or down
okay so vitamins are totally fine and I
recommend them when you're doing fasting
because you may be deficient and you
want to avoid any possible problem with
having some deficiency and then fasting
and then ending up feeling faint or
dizzy or whatever because you didn't
have that reserve okay then we have the
green powder okay you have the green
powder with the fiber and you have green
powder without the fiber as in
wheatgrass juice powder both of those
products really will create a
significant effect on insulin ketones
and weight loss I mean even one scoop of
the wheatgrass juice powder is less than
one carbohydrate so it's such a small
amount you don't have to worry about it
bone broth okay it really depends how
much bone broth you're consuming but
bone broth has protein in it and that
protein can increase insulin but it all
depends on the
quantity of course it's not gonna be the
same as eating a steak but there is
still protein in there because remember
carbohydrates protein and calories
getting increased insulin which can then
lower ketones now as far as weight loss
it really depends on the quantity that
you consume and how much insulin is
being spiked now if we go to college and
collagen has a bit more protein okay and
of course this depends on how much
you're consuming it's going to increase
insulin so it's not a good thing to
consume when you're fasting in fact both
of these are not a good thing to consume
when you're fasting because they're
going to lower ketones why even consume
them and depending on how much you
consume it may or may not affect your
weight loss then you have branched chain
amino acids now the problem with this is
there's only three amino acids you don't
have all the essential amino acids so
when you consume only three you cannot
build proteins it's impossible with
three amino acids so this is going to be
used primarily as fuel depending on what
type of protein you have whether it's
egg meat dairy soy whey protein you're
gonna have between 16 to 49 percent of
that protein actually turning into body
tissue turning into muscle or other
proteins that are in your body okay
that's at the very most and this is
basically I think it's 48 percent that's
an egg breast milk I think it's 49
percent that has the highest amount of
that protein turning into body tissues
I'm not talking about absorption I'm
talking about actually ending up in your
muscles in repair or rebuilding certain
proteins 60 percent to 48 percent
because we're not gonna talk about
breast milk because chances are you're
not consuming breast milk unless you're
a baby watching my video
okay so 16 to 40 percent of that okay
turns into body tissue that means that
52 to 84 percent
of that product is not turning in the
body tissue where is it going it's
either going on as waste as urea
nitrogen waste or it's being used as
fuel okay so it turns into glucose so a
lot of the protein that people consume
is not creating an anabolic effect which
is a building effect it's creating a
catabolic fact it's breaking down into a
carbohydrate an anabolic effect would be
the turning of protein into body tissue
but there is a group of amino acid in a
certain ratio that will absorb at 99
percent so only 1 percent of it is
wasted okay so that means 99% of it is
anabolic this is something that you
could do during a fast especially around
your workout because you're not getting
the insulin spike in fact a lot of it is
not even ending up as calories because
it's being converted anabolic ly2 body
tissue especially if you're not taking a
tremendous amount you're just doing the
right amount for your body to use to
create a building anabolic effect
alright so we already talked about
aspartame right here sugar alcohols I'm
gonna put a link of a video just on
sugar alcohols because I cover this in
depth but I just want to give you a
summarized version with this right here
so you have a wreath rotol which has a
zero effect on the glycemic index so
that's not going to affect insulin for
ketones or weightloss however some
people have a lot of digestive issues
with that and sometimes they will retain
water so they may may gain weight on it
but it's water weight so you don't want
to do too much then you have xylitol
which is 30 on the glycemic index so if
you're consuming a very small amount of
it let's say in your coffee it'll have a
very small effect on insulin and ketosis
however it does have an effect so it
really depends on your goals and how
slow your metabolism is and what you're
trying to achieve then you have
something called maltitol
which is a type of sugar alcohol that is
the absolute worst it's like over 50 so
you want to stay away from that one and
then there are other things like corn
fiber and inulin I have noticed that
people have a lot of digestive issues
with those so again it may not trigger
insulin or affect ketones but it you can
have some water retention with that now
when we get to stevia or a monk fruit
those will have a zero effect on insulin
and ketosis in weight loss so you can do
those without any problem at all fiber
in general has a zero effect on insulin
and ketosis and I'm talking about the
fiber from vegetables and not talking
about bran which actually has the it's
loaded with something called phytic acid
which could block your zinc iron and
other minerals and the other thing is if
you're taking just straight fiber as
inulin or like in chicory root or
something like corn fiber which could be
GMO so you might gain weight on this but
this is not actual fat its water
retention so this usually happens after
your you get this little keto dessert
and you buy it from something and you
consume it and then you feel bloated and
you get really thirsty and you start
drinking water and then your stomach
gets more bloated well that's really
what's happening so some people can get
away with it some people can't okay what
about half and half and your coffee or
cream well depends how much you consume
I don't have a problem with it okay
especially if it's grass-fed or organic
I prefer cream to half and a half
because half and a half has a little
more carbs but if you're only doing a
small amount I would not worry about
this because it's going to create just
the insignificant effect on insulin and
ketones maybe it's going to bump you out
of ketosis possibly for 20 minutes okay
but that's not significant then we have
actual butter or coconut oil which do
have a zero effect on insulin okay and
it can increase your ketones but you may
not lose any weight because your body is
using the dietary fat instead of your
own fat as fuel I've talked about that
in the last slide so just realize that
you could overdo it with the fat so if
you're struggling and it's not you're
not losing weight just cut back on the
fat I think the the magic amount of
grams that I would recommend if you're
struggling would be like something like
75 grams of fat per day and but you
don't want to go too low though so I
think this would be a good number if you
want to calculate that apple cider
vinegar okay is going to create a zero
effect on insulin ketones and weight
loss however it can help insulin
resistance it can improve your blood
Sugar's so it could actually help you
eventually get into a deeper ketosis and
help with weight loss but when you drink
it it's not giving you ketones right
away and then we have lemon juice okay
there are a small amount of carbs with
lemon juice so it really depends on how
much you consume if you're doing two
tablespoons I wouldn't worry about it
it's insignificant now sometimes people
do unsweetened cranberry juice that has
a little more carbs so you might want to
be careful with that because I have had
people consume unsweetened cranberry
juice and that stopped their weight loss
now if you have a regular cranberry
juice with the actual sugar that the add
in there and other juices that would be
really bad but I'm talking unsweetened
even though it's bitter there's a quite
a bit of carb in that product so I would
probably avoid that but lemon juice is
going to be fine now if you have a whole
cup you might have seven grams of carb
it's very small it's gonna bump you out
maybe for an hour or two but it's going
to be insignificant but normally people
are just doing a tablespoon or two which
I would not worry about alright I
covered a lot of information I hope you
now understand this a little bit better
and I hope you're not even more confused
but go ahead and review this and put
some comments down below if you have any
additional questions thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos